volvos have always had a reputation for
being safe cars
last but not least because of the tough
steel used to make them
but today he adds safety means more than
a solid car with good crash test results
it's all about electronics that are
supposed to prevent accidents now
volvo's a leader here and mata says he's
flown to gothenburg sweden to find out
more firsthand
volvo's new road edge and barrier
detection system with
steer assist recognizes possible dangers
and
automatically detects unintentional lane
deviations
meaning the driver is always supported
by automatic steering impulses
what looks like a technical gimmick at
first glance should later help
traffic slow more smoothly all by itself
parking is the first place volvo is
trying to make its autos autonomous
a driver can use a smartphone to tell
the car to find a parking space on its
own aided by sensors and gps
if it comes across other vehicles
obstacles or pedestrians the car stops
and waits until its path is clear
it seems to work like a charm but volvo
says it will take some time before it's
ready for series production
i would say that somewhere around five
to ten years from now
we can see cars parking autonomously in
in a parking
lot but there are of course also other
issues that need to be
to be discussed and resolved regarding
legal aspects and and liability issues
and and so there are many pieces of the
puzzle of autonomous parking that need
to be sold in order to to make this into
an end product
once the car has found its own parking
space and parked
it turns off its engine
connected to a smartphone the car can
even find its way back to you
the city safety system detects large
animals
such as moose for example in critical
situations the car will stop
itself
volvo already brought pedestrian
protection a big step forward a few
years ago with the city safety system
it has its own eyes with which to
determine whether someone is currently
crossing the road
and breaks automatically and the new
system is designed to work at night as
well
and to the dummy's relief it works
the camera has a range of exposure
settings so that even in the dark
it can detect an object in front of the
car and react accordingly
sounds and leds are used to alert
drivers
if they fail to take action the vehicle
will
remembers his dad's car having cruise
control when he was a boy
all the driver had to do was steer and
brake
back then he wondered how great it would
be if the car could also do the braking
automatically
that's nothing special these days it's
called adaptive cruise control
it modifies your speed to the car in
front
all that's
until now volvo is looking at a future
where you do no steering at all
adaptive cruise control with steer
assist why did the idea only occur to
them now
well we've been dreaming about
self-driving cars for a long time
but now the sensor technology the radars
the camera
is finally so mature that we actually
can steer the car automatically
but matus wants to know how it works
well the the radar and the camera they
detect the car in front so they know the
distance to the car in front and i know
the angle to the car in front
and this car is controlled in such a way
that it tries to follow the truck
the trick of the car in front and right
now i can release the steering wheel
but when we put this in a production
vehicle in a new xc90 next year
then it's required for the driver to
keep the hand on the steering wheel
to make sure that the driver is
supervising the system
mata says plenty of developments on the
horizon will make driving even easier
and safer
car to car communication as the name
suggests enables vehicles
to exchange data in order to improve
road safety
the system uses acoustic signals and
icon alerts
to warn the driver an approaching
emergency vehicle for example
it can also alert the driver to a
breakdown out of sight around the corner
in situations where a brief distraction
can be critical in terms of
driver response times the system is a
potential lifesaver
the car of the future also breaks
automatically in the dark
and to avoid animals it can navigate its
own way through
traffic and prevent smee from coming off
the road
it can park on its own and talk to its
fellow cars
that means smoother traffic flow and
fewer accidents
some of the ideas are still pipe dreams
and will need another 5
10 or 15 years to be standard features
but the signs
are clear there's plenty of road ahead
when it comes to safety technology
and comfort heights